This is 99% indiscible. I'm Roman Mars. In the shadow of Silicon Valley, San Francisco is home to a futuristic eatery with a virtual cashier putting change on the menu. There was a new restaurant that opened a few years back in downtown San Francisco. It was called Itza. Itza, a high-tech new restaurant where you order on iPads and get your quinoa bowls out of a cubby. And instead of placing an order with a waiter or someone behind the counter, you punch in your order on a screen. It's terrific for those of us who aren't any social. You don't have to actually talk to a person, just swipe your card. And then a few minutes later, you would walk to a wall of clear glass cubbies.
这里是99%隐形。我是罗曼·马尔斯。在硅谷的阴影下，旧金山有一家充满未来感的餐馆，它把找零也搬上了菜单。几年前，旧金山市中心开了一家新餐厅。它叫Itza。Itza是一家高科技新餐厅，你在iPad上点餐，然后从一个小壁橱里取走你的藜麦碗。你不用向服务员或柜台后面的人点餐，而是在屏幕上输入你的订单。对于我们这些有点社交恐惧的人来说，这太棒了。你实际上不需要和任何人说话，只需刷一下卡。几分钟后，你就可以走向一排透明的玻璃壁橱。
You'll go dark for just a second so you don't see the actual food being placed in the cubby. And then when the food was placed, the cubby would glow with your name. You'd tap the glass twice and you could open the cubby and your food order was in there, waiting for you. You tap it, you get your food and you leave. The fact that you can just order on the iPad, pick it out of the cubby and go back to your desk means it's really about the most productive way you can get lunch. You never had to interact with a single person if you didn't want to.
你会有一秒钟的时间陷入黑暗，这样你就不会看到真正的食物被放进壁橱里。然后，当食物放好后，壁橱里会亮起你的名字。你只要轻敲玻璃两下，就能打开壁橱，你的外卖就在里面等着你。你敲一下，拿到食物，然后离开。你只需在iPad上点餐，从壁橱里取出来，然后回到办公桌前，这意味着这真的是获取午餐最高效的方式。如果你不想的话，你永远不需要和任何人互动。
You didn't have the tip, it was fast, you could hop in, grab a custom made, quinoa bowl, and then go back to work without even pausing your podcast. And I hated it so much. Producer Avery Troubleman. As soon as I heard about Itza, I was like, okay, great. Just what we need. To be even more removed from our food. Not only where it comes from, but also the person who hands it to you.
你不需要付小费，速度很快，你可以顺便进去，拿一份定制的藜麦碗，然后回去工作，甚至都不用暂停你的播客。但我太讨厌它了。制作人艾弗里·特鲁布曼。我一听说Itza，就想，好吧，太好了。这正是我们所需要的。让我们与食物的距离更远。不仅是食物的来源，还有递给你食物的人。
Because it's not like it's a completely robot restaurant. There's still people back there, behind the cubbies, slicing your avocados. They're just conveniently placed out of sight so that you don't have to say thank you. Like, ah! But you never actually tried it. Okay, no. I never went there. So take it with a big fat pinch of salt.
因为这并不完全是一家机器人餐厅。后面壁橱后面仍然有人在为你切牛油果。他们只是被巧妙地隐藏在视线之外，这样你就不必说谢谢了。就像，啊！但你从来没有真正尝试过。好吧，没有。我从没去过那里。所以听听就算了，别太当真。
And also, know that I hated it because it was very fun to hate. It was like juicers that connect to your phone with Bluetooth. You know, just like stuff that is so completely lampoonably San Francisco. And so I did what I always do and I'm upset about a stupid thing. I tweeted about it.
而且，要知道我讨厌它是因为讨厌它很有趣。就像那些用蓝牙连接到你手机的榨汁机一样。你知道的，这完全就是那种极具旧金山市讽刺意味的东西。所以我做了我一贯做的事，我为一件蠢事感到心烦意乱。我在推特上发了牢骚。
And instead of getting in a fight, a number of people on Twitter pointed out that this restaurant is not a distinctly modern phenomenon. Something very similar existed at the turn of the century, over 100 years ago. And it was not a San Francisco thing. It was very New York. Something very similar existed at the turn of the century, over 100 years ago. And it was not a San Francisco thing. It was very New York.
Twitter上的许多人并没有跟我吵架，而是指出这家餐厅并不是一个明显的现代现象。在世纪之交，也就是100多年前，就存在非常类似的东西。而且这不是旧金山的专利。它非常具有纽约特色。在世纪之交，也就是100多年前，就存在非常类似的东西。而且这不是旧金山的专利。它非常具有纽约特色。
I grew up in this city, and the city that I grew up in, and the city I'm living in now, ain't never met each other. This is one of the New York-iest people I have ever met. Lorraine Deal. Well, I write about New York history, so I'm always fishing around for something that I want to write about. My grandmother lived on 42nd Street and 8th Avenue. I used to meet her under the clock
我在这个城市长大，我长大的城市，和我现在生活的城市，简直风马牛不相及。这是我见过的最具纽约特色的人之一。洛林·迪尔。嗯，我写纽约历史，所以我总是在搜寻我想写的东西。我祖母住在42街和8大道交汇处。过去我总是在星期六下午去时钟下面见她
of the Franklin Savings Bank on Saturday afternoon. We will go to Horn and Hard Art. Ask anyone who was a kid in New York in the 50s or 60s. They went to Horn and Hard Art. It was a popular restaurant chain that was, in many ways, the Itza of the 20th century. It had locations all over New York City and Philadelphia, and it had very solid, standard fare.
富兰克林储蓄银行。我们会去霍恩和哈达特。问问任何一个在50年代或60年代在纽约长大的人。他们都去过霍恩和哈达特。这是一个受欢迎的连锁餐厅，在许多方面，它就是20世纪的Itza。它在纽约市和费城到处都有分店，而且提供非常扎实、标准的食物。
We're talking literal meat and potatoes. What was your favorite dish? Oh, it was Salah's very steak and mashed potatoes. And when Lorraine decided that she wanted to write about Horn and Hard Art, she got connected with Marianne. People don't always connect my last name with Horn and Hard Art, but when they do, immediately stories start to come. Marianne Hard Art is the great granddaughter of Horn and Hard Art co-founder, Frank Hard Art.
我们要说的是名副其实的鱼肉和土豆。你最喜欢的菜是什么？哦，那是萨拉的顶级牛排配土豆泥。当洛林决定写关于霍恩和哈达特的故事时，她通过关系认识了玛丽安。人们并不总是把我的姓氏与霍恩和哈达特联系起来，但当他们这样做时，故事就会源源不断地涌现出来。玛丽安·哈达特是霍恩和哈达特联合创始人弗兰克·哈达特的曾孙女。
Together, Marianne Hard Art and Lorraine Deal teamed up to write the definitive history of this restaurant chain. Turns out these two live near each other on the upris side and they get along like a house on fire. You didn't step on each other's toes at all. Yeah, no. But Horn and Hard Art restaurants also went by another name, a much more famous name. The Automat. So what's the Automat? So it was the Automat? So it was the first time that you could go up to a wall,
玛丽安·哈达特和洛林·迪尔联手撰写了这家连锁餐厅的权威历史。原来这两个人住在上西区附近，他们一拍即合。你们俩一点也没有踩到对方的脚趾吗？是的，没有。但是霍恩和哈达特餐厅还有一个名字，一个更著名的名字。自动售货餐厅。那么什么是自动售货餐厅？所以这就是自动售货餐厅？所以这是你第一次可以走到一面墙前，
put money in and get food, hot or cold. Fresh prepared. Inside a horn and hard-hurt automatic, it looked like a glamorous or neat cafeteria. But instead of a human-handing, you hot food over a steaming counter, you'd push your tray up to a wall of little glass cubbies, each housing a fresh hot portion of food on a small plate. Maybe it would be a side of peas, maybe a turkey sandwich or
投入硬币就能买到热的或冷的食物。新鲜出炉。霍恩和哈达特自动餐厅内部看起来像一个光鲜亮丽或整洁的自助餐厅。但你不是从冒着热气的柜台后面由人工递给你热食，而是把托盘推到一排小玻璃壁橱前，每个壁橱都在一个小盘子上盛着新鲜热腾腾的食物。也许是一份豌豆，也许是一个火鸡三明治，或者
a slice of pie, and you put in some nickels, and then the door to that cubby would unlock, and you could just take the plate that was inside. That food was yours. This place where you could put money in a slot and pick your own food, so for children, you know, the parents would give them some money, they would run up to the windows, they could pick what they wanted, they could put the nickel in and get their own food. It was a really cheap. By the way, I hear the Beast take pie as a magnificent six nickels. And it was pretty good.
一块馅饼，你投入几个五分硬币，那个壁橱的门就会解锁，你就可以直接拿走里面的盘子。那食物就是你的了。你可以把钱投进一个槽里，然后挑选你自己的食物，所以对于孩子们来说，你知道，父母会给他们一些钱，他们会跑到窗前，挑选他们想要的，他们可以把五分硬币投进去，得到他们自己的食物。这真的很便宜。顺便说一句，我听说那里的牛排馅饼只要六个五分硬币，简直太棒了。而且味道相当不错。
Don't be a second sister, that beef pie is a while. You see automats in a ton of movies, ranging from silent films like The Early Bird in 1925 to Witt Stillman's Metropolitan in 1990. I think I'll have a cake or two next year. Yeah, I don't know, I like them a quake, wait, wait. Seeing a character in an automat tells you there's a certain kind of American, one who wants to go out to eat, but doesn't have the budget.
别当老二，那个牛肉馅饼吃好久。你在大量的电影里都能看到自动售货餐厅，从1925年的《早起的鸟儿》这样的无声电影，到威特·斯蒂尔曼1990年的《大都会》。我想我明年要吃一两个蛋糕。是的，我不知道，我喜欢它们。看到一个角色在自动售货餐厅出现，说明这是一种特定类型的美国人，他们想出去吃饭，但预算有限。
But my dear, she has no background. Like in this short, from 1932, one would hardly want to be seen dining out with her. It opens with a group of people in fancy hats, dining like royals, then the camera zooms out and womp, womp, they're in an automat. And this is also a punchline when Marilyn Monroe sings, Diamonds are a girl's best friend. And none of these movies explain what the automat is. It's just assumed that everyone knew. The Broadway columns in the newspapers are talking about who was seen at the
但是亲爱的，她没有背景。就像1932年的这部短片里，人们几乎不想看到有人和她一起在外用餐。影片开始时，一群戴着华丽帽子的的人像皇室一样用餐，然后镜头拉远，哇，哇，他们在自动售货餐厅。这也是玛丽莲·梦露演唱《钻石是女孩最好的朋友》时的妙语。这些电影都没有解释什么是自动售货餐厅。人们只是默认每个人都知道。报纸上的百老汇专栏讨论了谁被发现在
Automat. Jean Kelly when he was doing Pal Joey on Broadway. He and his wife would go over there and Gregory Peck would love their scrambled eggs or something. Counts and Countesses coming in from Europe, we've got to try this. And they would sit down next to people who were flat broke. And you didn't have to tip. No, which is kind of like itza. And that was the automat 110 years ago. The story of the automat started when Joe Horn met Frank Hardart.
自动售货餐厅。吉恩·凯利在百老汇表演《小乔》时。他和他的妻子会去那里，格里高利·派克会喜欢他们的炒鸡蛋之类的东西。伯爵和伯爵夫人从欧洲赶来，我们一定要尝尝这个。他们会坐在身无分文的人旁边。而且你不需要给小费。不，这有点像Itza。这就是110年前的自动售货餐厅。自动售货餐厅的故事始于乔·霍恩遇到弗兰克·哈达特。
Joe had put an ad in a local Philadelphia paper seeking a business partner. And so they got together and they opened a luncheon at in Philadelphia. 1888. 1888, okay, over to you. None of that's it. Just adding a year. 1888. And for a while it was just a normal luncheon at, with famously good coffee. Until Frank Hardart went over to Germany, right? He was going to give himself a vacation. Their Hardart encountered some very early German
乔在当地的一家费城报纸上登了一则广告，寻找商业合作伙伴。于是他们聚在一起，在费城开了一家午餐馆。1888年。1888年，好吧，交给你了。没有那回事。只是加了个年份。1888年。有一段时间，这只是一家普通的午餐馆，以极其美味的咖啡闻名。直到弗兰克·哈达特去了德国，对吧？他是去给自己放个假的。在那里，哈达特遇到了一些非常早期的德国
vending machine technology. Hardart bought one of these machines and brought it back to Philly. It was more... Ruben Goldberg contraption. Ruben Goldberg is anymore. You say that, you know how Ruben Goldberg is? With this overly complicated German vending contraption,
自动售货机技术。哈达特买下了其中一台机器，并把它带回了费城。这更像是……鲁布·戈德堡式的机械装置。鲁布·戈德堡已经过时了。你这么说，你知道鲁布·戈德堡是谁吗？通过这个过于复杂的德国自动售货装置，
the food in the windows was a sample display of what one could order. Customers would deposit a coin and wait around while someone in the basement cooked it and then cranked it up in a dumb waiter. It was a very convoluted way of getting your food, but everyone loved the novelty of it. So they perfected it and then they brought it to New York City. Yeah. And the New York City about 10 years later. 10 years later. So it was in Philadelphia. The first automat was 1902 and then they came to New York City in 1912. And now equipped with the glass cubbies, the automatic caught on fast,
橱窗里的食物是可以点餐的样品展示。顾客存入一枚硬币，然后在一旁等待，而地下室的人则将其煮熟，然后用传菜梯把它送上来。这是一种获取食物的非常曲折的方式，但每个人都喜欢它的新鲜感。所以他们完善了它，然后把它带到了纽约市。是的。大约10年后来到了纽约市。10年之后。所以它在费城。第一家自动售货餐厅是1902年，然后他们在1912年来到了纽约市。现在配备了玻璃壁橱，自动售货餐厅迅速流行起来，
but not because of the technology. That was just to get people in the door. The automatic part was just as glorious gimmick. People came for the novelty, but came back again and again because it was solid, good, food, and cheap. The technology was just a mechanical Turk. The only thing that was automatic was when you went in there and looked at this wall, but what was going on behind those walls is very different. Behind the scenes, there were people scurrying around replacing all the food.
但不是因为技术。那只是为了把人们吸引进门。自动售货部分只是一个光鲜亮丽的噱头。人们为了新鲜感而来，但一次又一次地回来是因为这里的食物扎实、美味且便宜。这项技术只是一种机械土耳其人。唯一自动的是当你走进那里看着这堵墙的时候，但这些墙后面发生的事情却截然不同。在幕后，人们跑来跑去更换所有的食物。
Past the vending walls were scores of workers, many of whom were recent immigrants, rapidly replenishing the food into the cupis, and darting out to bust and clean dishware. And as Automats expanded to more locations in both Philadelphia and New York, all the cooking itself happened in off-site commissaries. These were separate kitchens and they took up a whole city block.
自动售货墙后面有成群的工人，其中许多是新移民，他们迅速将食物补充到橱柜中，并冲出去收拾和清洗餐具。随着自动售货餐厅在费城和纽约扩展到更多地点，所有的烹饪本身都在场外中央厨房进行。这些是独立的厨房，占据了整个城市街区。
There's one giant central commissary in New York and one giant central commissary in Philly, and both were full of vats of sauces and pies by the hundreds which dispatched hot and fresh to all the automats throughout the day. The food for the New York locations was slightly different than fillies. There were little regional variations. For mac and cheese, I think one had diced tomatoes and it and the other one didn't. You know, there were some things like that.
纽约有一个巨大的中央厨房，费城也有一个巨大的中央厨房，这两个厨房都装满了成百上千的酱汁桶和馅饼，全天候向各个自动售货餐厅分发热腾腾的新鲜食物。纽约分店的食物和费城的略有不同。有一些细微的地区差异。对于通心粉和奶酪，我想其中一个里面有切碎的番茄，而另一个没有。你知道，有一些类似的事情。
I feel like they like things spicier. Their taste was a little bit sharper than New York's taste. Are people or sharper? Their food was sharper. But all the restaurants were very united in how they looked. Joe Horn and Frank Hart, it made it their business to make sure that when you walked into these places, they were really quite lovely. I mean, some of them were just art deco-palaces.
我觉得他们喜欢味道更辣的东西。他们的口味比纽约的口味更浓烈一些。是人更浓烈还是口味更浓烈？他们的食物味道更浓烈。但所有的餐厅在外观上都非常统一。乔·霍恩和弗兰克·哈达特把确保你走进这些地方时它们真的很可爱作为他们的业务。我的意思是，其中一些简直就是装饰艺术宫殿。
They were beautiful. And that, to me, is a generosity of spirit because they know they're not getting the carriage trade coming in every day, owing it on, and asking for the wine list. There are those rare brands that appeal across economic classes, like IKEA and Target. Horn and Hard Art was one of them. The automatic was a place where anyone could eat.
它们太美了。对我来说，这是一种精神上的慷慨，因为他们知道每天进出这里的不是坐着马车、赊账并索要酒单的上流社会。有些罕见的品牌能够吸引不同经济阶层的消费者，比如宜家和塔吉特。霍恩和哈达特就是其中之一。自动售货餐厅是一个任何人都可以吃饭的地方。
In a time when it was nearly unheard of for a woman to go out to eat alone, or for people to just post up somewhere all day. And with the automatic, they could without shame. And people who were just saving face or saving shoe leather, looking for jobs, would be in there nursing a cup of coffee all day and no one bothered them. We didn't even know that people would eat that way and then as soon as they could. They could. Exactly. And also people could eat as much or as little as they could, you know, they had total
在那个时代，女人独自一人外出吃饭，或者人们只是在某个地方待上一整天几乎是闻所未闻的。有了自动售货餐厅，他们可以毫无羞耻地这样做。那些为了面子或省下鞋底钱而寻找工作的人，可以在那里喝上一整天咖啡，没有人打扰他们。我们甚至不知道人们会那样吃饭，但只要他们能够，他们就会这样做。他们确实可以。没错。而且人们可以根据自己的能力多吃或少吃，你知道的，他们拥有完全的
autonomy. I just want a cup of coffee. I really just want five pieces of dessert. I want this. I want that. And you didn't have to deal with what you should be ordering or how to order. And it could be quick. It could be leisurely.
自主权。我只是想要一杯咖啡。我真的只想吃五份甜点。我想要这个。我想要那个。你不需要去纠结你应该点什么或者如何点餐。而且可以很快。也可以很悠闲。
You with a boss. And because everyone ate there, that's how they could keep it so cheap. It was all economies of scale. That's how they made so much food, so fresh and so affordable. It was all volume. Before McDonald's,
你和老板在一起。正因为每个人都在那里吃饭，他们才能保持如此低廉的价格。这完全是规模经济。这就是他们制作如此大量、新鲜且实惠的食物的方式。全靠走量。在麦当劳之前，
Hornin Hard Art was the largest restaurant chain in America and one of the largest in the world. This is Lisa Herwitz, a filmmaker working on a documentary about the automatic. And by largest, I'm talking about volume. Just stop to imagine that for a second. Somehow, everyone knew about the automatic.
霍恩和哈达特是美国最大的连锁餐厅，也是世界上最大的连锁餐厅之一。这是莉萨·赫维茨，一位正在拍摄一部关于自动售货餐厅纪录片的电影制作人。我所说的最大，是指营业额。停下来想象一下，就那么一秒钟。不知何故，每个人都知道自动售货餐厅。
Marilyn Monroe was singing about it. It was in a ton of movies. Horn and Hard Art fed more people than any other restaurant in the United States. And it was only in two cities, New York and Philadelphia. For a lot of people, they never could have imagined that Hornet Harder was ever going to disappear because it was such a big part of the fabric
玛丽莲·梦露在歌唱它。它出现在大量的电影中。霍恩和哈达特喂饱的人比美国任何其他餐厅都多。而且它只在纽约和费城这两个城市存在。对很多人来说，他们从未想过霍恩和哈达特会消失，因为它是纽约市和费城社会结构中如此重要的一部分。
of New York City of Philadelphia. Today, I can't ever imagine Starbucks disappearing, but it could one day, you never know. I think maybe Hornet Harder got a little too comfortable, and they couldn't imagine what was about to happen. What happened to the automat was the story of the American city. White flight and mass migration to the suburbs.
今天，我无法想象星巴克会消失，但总有一天它可能会消失，你永远说不准。我想也许霍恩和哈达特变得有点太自满，他们无法想象即将发生的事情。自动售货餐厅的遭遇正是美国城市发展史的一个缩影。白人群体外迁以及向郊区的大规模移民。
Americans had new homes with new cars and new lifestyles. And of course, this changed how people ate. It became very trendy for women to be stay at home, mothers, taking care of new homes, using their new kitchens, taking care of the family, and that meant less eating out. So while automates used to be seven-day-a-week, three-meal-a-day operations, they transformed into five-day-a-week, one-meal-a-day operations. And the people who into five day a week, one meal a day operations.
美国人住上了新房子，开上了新汽车，有了新生活方式。当然，这也改变了人们的饮食方式。全职家庭主妇变得非常流行，她们照顾新家，使用新厨房，照顾家人，这意味着在外就餐减少了。因此，过去每周七天、一天三餐运转的自动售货餐厅，变成了每周五天、一天一餐的运转模式。而那些
And the people who went out to eat for that one meal didn't want 20 cents stakes anymore. If you were on the go, now there was fast food. If you wanted to sit, you wanted white tablecloths and an attentive waiters and fancier food that you couldn't cook at home. People had more money to spend. They were more inclined to have maybe fewer meals out,
出来吃那一顿饭的人，再也不想要20美分的牛排了。如果你行色匆匆，现在有了快餐。如果你想坐下来，你会想要白桌布、周到的服务员以及你在家里做不出来的更高级的食物。人们有更多的钱可以花。他们可能更倾向于减少在外就餐的次数，
but to have nicer meals. Horn and Hard Arts were getting old and looking kind of bedraggled. Customers and city governments were investing less and less in the increasingly neglected inner cities around them. And so Horn and Hard Art launches their big comeback ad campaign, in which they dig launches their big comeback ad campaign, in which they dig in their heels and refuse to change it all.
但要吃得更好。霍恩和哈达特餐厅正在变老，看起来有点破烂不堪。顾客和市政府对周围日益被忽视的内城区的投入越来越少。于是霍恩和哈达特推出了他们盛大的复出广告活动，在这个活动中，他们坚守立场，拒绝做出任何改变。
If you want something nice to look at when you eat at Horn and Hard Art, we suggest you keep an eye on your plate. The campaign was called It's Not Fancy, but it's good. Although eventually, it wasn't even that good. When Horn and Hard Art got less popular, the food turnover wasn't as high, so it wasn't as fresh. But there was something going on simultaneously, which was that the horns and the hard arts
如果你想在霍恩和哈达特用餐时看到一些赏心目中的东西，我们建议你盯着你的盘子。这个活动被称为“不花哨，但很好”。不过最终，它甚至连这个标准都达不到。当霍恩和哈达特变得不那么受欢迎时，食物的周转率就不那么高了，所以也就不那么新鲜了。但与此同时发生了一件事，那就是霍恩和哈达特家族
were being pushed out of the company, and the new people who weren't auto-mat people, they were fast food people. The new heads of horn and hard art realized that their greatest asset was not their restaurants, but their real estate. So the really prime Horn and Hard Art locations were franchised into fast food restaurants. They were the first Burger King, Arby's franchisees in Manhattan.
被挤出了公司，而新来的人不是自动售货餐厅的人，他们是快餐业的人。霍恩和哈达特的新领导层意识到，他们最大的资产不是他们的餐厅，而是他们的房地产。因此，真正优质的霍恩和哈达特地段被特许经营成了快餐店。他们是曼哈顿最早的汉堡王和阿比斯加盟店。
The Automat lasted the better part of the century, which is pretty incredible for any business. The last Automat in New York, which choked along pretty much as a gimmick, finally closed in 1991. I will admit that where I felt only disdain for Itza, I was totally taken in by the idea of the automat. Like 100% sign me up for this place that is both highbrow and lowbrow, where I can eat in a beautiful art deco dining room and have as many slices of pie as I want without judgment. And sure, some of that is just baseless nostalgia, and a genuine love of art deco dining room and have as many slices of pie as I want without judgment. And sure, some of that is just baseless nostalgia and a genuine love of art deco.
自动售货餐厅持续了大半个世纪，对于任何企业来说这都是相当不可思议的。纽约最后一家自动售货餐厅基本上靠着噱头勉强维持，最终于1991年关门大吉。我必须承认，我对Itza只有蔑视，但我却完全被自动售货餐厅的概念迷住了。100%让我加入这个地方，它既高雅又通俗，我可以在一个美丽的装饰艺术餐厅里用餐，想吃多少块馅饼就吃多少块，而不用担心受到评判。当然，其中一部分只是毫无根据的怀旧，以及对装饰艺术餐厅的真挚喜爱，想吃多少块馅饼就吃多少块，而不用判断。当然，其中一部分只是毫无根据的怀旧和对装饰艺术的真挚热爱。
But I think there's a reason Horn in Hard Art was in business for a hundred years. And I think it's because it was always a very human experience. It wasn't to go containers, it was metal, flatware, and China. Customers stayed in the dining room to eat, so it was always full of people hanging out. And ultimately, humans seem to crave some kind of interaction when they go out to eat, even today. People aren't necessarily looking for an all-robot kind of experience. I mean, when they walk in, they want it to be easy and convenient, and they want to, if they have an issue,
但我认为霍恩和哈达特能经营一百年是有原因的。我认为这是因为它始终是一种非常有人情味的人类体验。它不是外卖盒，而是金属餐具和中国瓷器。顾客们留在餐厅里用餐，所以这里总是挤满了闲逛的人。归根结底，人们在外面吃饭时似乎渴望某种互动，即使在今天也是如此。人们不一定在寻找全自动的体验。我的意思是，当他们走进去时，他们希望一切都简单方便，如果他们遇到问题，
be able to communicate to someone who can take care of them. This is Gwyneth Borden, the executive director of the Golden Gate Restaurant Association, which is the trade association for the restaurants in the San Francisco Bay Area. 2015 was the first year in the US when the Department of Commerce was tracking that people spent more money on dine-out food than groceries. And increasingly, what we have seen as food is the modern form of entertainment. Demand for restaurants is up, which means there's a national shortage
能够与能照顾他们的人沟通。这是格温妮丝·博登，金门餐馆协会的执行董事，该协会是旧金山湾区餐馆的贸易协会。2015年是美国商务部追踪到人们在外出就餐上的花费超过杂货费用的第一年。而且我们越来越多地看到，食物成为了现代形式的娱乐。餐馆的需求上升了，这意味着全国范围内都存在短缺
of restaurant workers, especially in expensive cities like San Francisco, where the median cost of a one bedroom apartment is now $3,700 a month. How do you pay for that while working in a restaurant? As labor costs overall, risen, it's hard to define people to work in farming, it's harder to find people working restaurants, so you have to pay people more. So restaurants have been trying to get by with fewer people, with self-ordering screens or counter-service, where you just grab a
餐馆工人短缺，尤其是在旧金山这样昂贵的城市，一居室公寓的中位价现在每月高达3700美元。在餐馆工作怎么付得起这笔钱？随着整体劳动力成本的上升，很难找到人在农业工作，也很难找到人在餐馆工作，所以你必须付给人们更多的钱。因此，餐馆一直在试图用更少的人来应付，使用自助点餐屏幕或柜台服务，你只需拿一个
number for your table. But this can be taken too far. What we know, for fact, is that people will eat in a mediocre restaurant for food food but won't accept bad service. If you look at Yelp or TripAdvisor or whatever, you see in people's reviews that service is a really important factor. In general, yes, people write things about the food not being great, but it's what usually drives them to do that is a bad experience where they feel like they were not seen or heard. So rather than hiding the workers in the back and automating the front of the house, like Izza or the automat, some new automated restaurants are trying to flip it. They want the food to be served entirely by humans, but it's cooked by robots. I went to one of these places in San Francisco.
桌子号码牌。但这可能会走得太远。我们所知道的事实是，人们会为了食物去一家平庸的餐厅吃饭，但不会接受糟糕的服务。如果你看Yelp、猫途鹰或其他什么，你会发现在人们的评论中，服务是一个非常重要的因素。总的来说，是的，人们会写一些关于食物不是很好的评论，但通常促使他们这样做的原因是糟糕的体验，他们觉得没有被看到或听到。因此，与其把工人生硬地藏在后面并自动化前台，比如Izza或自动售货餐厅，一些新的自动化餐厅正试图颠覆这种做法。他们希望食物完全由人工服务，但由机器人烹饪。我在旧金山去过这样一家店。
It's a robot burger restaurant called Creator, but where people greet you and guide you through the menu and place your order for you. And then clear glass robots assemble your burger in under five minutes. But then a human calls out your name and hands your order to you. And the secret power of this restaurant is not a central commissary kitchen. It's the 40-some-odd engineers working in the office next door. Because whether they automate the front or the back,
这是一家名为Creator的机器人汉堡餐厅，那里有人迎接你，引导你浏览菜单并为你下单。然后透明玻璃机器人会在不到五分钟的时间内为你组装汉堡。但随后会有一个真人喊出你的名字并把订单交给你。这家餐厅的秘密武器不是中央厨房。而是隔壁办公室的40多名工程师。因为无论是前端自动化还是后端自动化，
these businesses are not just selling food. They are selling their technology. And that's true for ETSA. They've gone from selling keenwobbles to selling their service system. Their two locations in San Francisco are now shuttered, with no signs of when they'll open again. Itza wouldn't go on record for an interview, but their PR representative told me that now Itza is focused on selling their serving technology to other chains, like a macaroni and cheese restaurant called Mact, and another chain called Wow Bow.
这些企业不只是在销售食物。它们在销售它们的技术。ETSAT也是如此。它们已经从销售藜麦碗转向销售它们的服务系统。它们在旧金山的两个分店现在已经关门大吉，没有任何迹象表明它们何时会重新开业。Itza不愿公开接受采访，但他们的公关代表告诉我，现在Itza专注于将他们的服务技术出售给其他连锁店，比如一家名为Mact的通心粉和奶酪餐厅，以及另一家名为Wow Bow的连锁店。
Even at McDonald's, it's pretty common to order on a screen. And a salad making robot named Sally is being put in a restaurant chain based in Louisiana, Mississippi, and Alabama. There are new iterations of vending machines and faceless delivery and robot chefs popping up everywhere. The point is yes, Horn and Hard Art restaurants are gone, but more and more chains are becoming automats. Special thanks to Row Flag, David Bordeaux, and Emouna Hauser, and Ira Galtman.
即使在麦当劳，在屏幕上点餐也很常见。一个名为萨利的制作沙拉的机器人正在被引入总部位于路易斯安那州、密西西比州和亚阿拉巴马州的连锁餐厅。自动售货机、无脸外卖和机器人厨师的新迭代到处涌现。关键是，是的，霍恩和哈达特餐厅已经消失了，但越来越多的连锁餐厅正在变成自动售货餐厅。特别感谢罗·弗拉格、大卫·波尔多、埃莫娜·豪瑟和艾拉·加尔特曼。
You can find out more about Lisa Herwood's documentary and share your automatic memories at facebook.com slash the automatic the movie. Coming up, robots that throw food, all in an effort to make that food seem more delicious. After this. When we were editing this story about the auto mat, it brought to mind another story about robots and food that we did a couple of years back that I love because it may be the most perfect example of the 99% invisible effort that goes into something that most people do not think about at all,
你可以了解更多关于莉萨·赫维茨的纪录片的信息，并在facebook.com slash the automatic the movie上分享你的自动售货餐厅记忆。接下来，会扔食物的机器人，这一切都是为了让食物看起来更美味。广告之后见。当我们剪辑这个关于自动售货餐厅的故事时，它让我想起了几年前我们做的另一个关于机器人和食物的故事，我非常喜欢它，因为它可能是99%隐形技术投入的最完美例证，而大多数人根本不会去想这些，
but it totally changed the way we buy and consume food. Check it out. Malser watering, lemons are squeezing, and stomachs are growling. Of all the ads you see on TV, or on billboards, or on the sides of buses, an overwhelming number seem to be, for food.
但它彻底改变了我们购买和消费食物的方式。来看看吧。柠檬汁四溅，柠檬在挤压，肚子在咕咕叫。在你电视上看到的、或者广告牌上看到的、或者公交车身的所有广告中，绝大多数似乎都是关于食物的。
This is our masterpiece. Boorshead of an gold turkey, eggs and sausage, hotcakes and butter. I see coaks in frosted glasses, fajitas sizzling on the grill. A guy biting into the perfect hamburger on a sesame seed bun. But of course, you know, in real life, these foods don't look like they do in the ads. I'm here with a question from Isabel M from Toronto, Ontario. She asks, why does your food look different in the advertising than what's in the store?
这是我们的杰作。Boorshead的黄金火鸡，鸡蛋和香肠，热蛋糕和黄油。我看到冰镇玻璃杯里的可乐，烤架上滋滋作响的法式烤肉。一个人咬着芝麻面包上的完美汉堡。当然，你知道，在现实生活中，这些食物看起来并不像广告里那样。我这里有来自安大略省多伦多的伊莎贝尔·M的一个问题。她问，为什么你的食物在广告中看起来与店里的不同？
It's a great question from Isabel M from Toronto, Ontario. She asks, why does your food look different in the advertising than what's in the store? It's a great question, Isabel. We can ask that a lot. And if you want to come with me, I'm going to take you across the street. We're going to find out a bit more. In 2012, McDonald's Canada put out this video about the process they go through to photograph
这是来自安大略省多伦多的伊莎贝尔·M的一个很好的问题。她问，为什么你的食物在广告中看起来与店里的不同？这是一个很好的问题，伊莎贝尔。我们经常被问到这个问题。如果你愿意跟我来，我要带你过马路。我们会去了解更多信息。2012年，加拿大麦当劳发布了这段关于他们制作一个汉堡的摄影过程的视频。
one of their burgers. What I'm going to do is introduce you now to Noah, who's our food stylist. And here I think that's important to note that all the ingredients that Noah uses are the exact same ingredients that we use in the restaurant. The video follows food stylist Noah as he painstakingly selects the perfect slices of onion and pickle. He places them on the burger with tweezers and then precisely melts the cheese just so. So I'm just melting down the cheese with my palette knife. Then he picks up a plastic syringe filled with ketchup
我现在要为你介绍的是我们的食品造型师诺亚。这里我认为值得注意的是，诺亚使用的所有食材与我们在餐厅使用的食材完全相同。视频跟随食品造型师诺亚，他精心地挑选出完美的洋葱片和酸黄瓜。他用镊子把它们放在汉堡上，然后恰到好处地融化奶酪。所以我只是用调色刀把奶酪融化。然后他拿起一个装满番茄酱的塑料注射器，
and applies it with surgical precision. Maybe I'll put the mustard ketchup, actually ketchup, mustard ketchup. Then they photograph this fancy burger and Photoshop it to perfection. That's nice. They placed a picture of a real burger just ordered at McDonald's
以外科手术般的精确度涂抹上去。也许我会把芥末番茄酱放上去，实际上是番茄酱、芥末番茄酱。然后他们给这个漂亮的汉堡拍照，并用Photoshop把它精修到完美。真不错。他们把一张刚在麦当劳订购的真实汉堡的照片放在了
next to the image of this stylized burger. And the difference is striking. That's reporter Danny Lewis. I would like to eat the burger that Noah styled and disempled. The other one, not so much. The last 100 years or so of food advertising have been shaped by this one simple fact. Real food looks bad on camera.
这款经过造型的汉堡图像旁边。两者的差异令人瞩目。那是记者丹尼·刘易斯。我想吃诺亚造型和组装的汉堡。另一个嘛，就算了吧。过去100年左右的食品广告都是由这一个简单的事实塑造的。真实的食物在镜头前看起来很糟糕。
Shooting food and even photographing food has always been fiendishly difficult in advertising. This is Terry O'Reilly. For decades, he was an ad man, and he now hosts a radio show about advertising called Under the Influence. Terry says the challenges of shooting food are obvious. First of all, food is boring to look at when it's just sitting on a plate. Because food is generally static. Then, when you subject it to the hot lights of a studio, the food starts to wilt. It's just simple science. And so advertisers have had to constantly walk this fine line between enhancement and fakery, trying all kinds of tricks to get food to look good.
拍摄食物甚至给食物拍照在广告中一直都极其困难。这是特里·奥赖利。几十年来，他一直是一名广告人，现在他主持一个关于广告的广播节目，名叫《潜移默化》。特里说，拍摄食物的挑战是显而易见的。首先，食物只是静静地放在盘子里时看起来很无聊。因为食物通常是静态的。然后，当你把它置于工作室炽热的灯光下时，食物就开始枯萎了。这只是简单的科学。因此，广告商不得不不断在美化和造假之间走钢丝，尝试各种技巧来让食物看起来很好看。
For the first half of the 20th century, well after photography was widely adopted, advertisers and magazines and newspapers relied heavily on illustration. The reason illustration was the preferred method was because you can completely control an illustration. In other words, there's no lighting issues, there's no wilting food issues. A marketer could really completely dictate what that food would look like right down to the strand of pasta with an illustrator. Then TV came along in the 1950s and 60s,
在20世纪的前半叶，也就是摄影被广泛采用很久之后，杂志和报纸上的广告商严重依赖插图。插图成为首选方法的原因是你可以完全控制插图。换句话说，没有灯光问题，没有食物枯萎的问题。营销人员真的可以用插画家完全支配食物的外观，甚至精确到一根面条。然后电视在20世纪50年代和60年代兴起，
and advertisers faced a whole new set of challenges. I'm going to show you how McDonald's builds a big max sandwich. A lot of them didn't really understand how to shoot food in a compelling way. In this ad, the hamburger just sits there on the counter for the ingredients to get piled on. It starts here with a lightly toasted bun, and then a pure beef hamburger. the ingredients get piled on. Without compelling visuals, there'd often be a voiceover, just describing the hell out
广告商面临着一系列全新的挑战。我将向你们展示麦当劳是如何制作巨无霸三明治的。他们中的许多人并不真正懂得如何以引人注目的方式拍摄食物。在这则广告中，汉堡就那样放在柜台上，等待着各种食材堆叠上去。它从一个略微烤过的面包开始，然后是一块纯牛肉汉堡。各种食材堆叠上去。如果没有引人注目的视觉效果，通常会有画外音，大肆渲染
of the food. Listing ingredients, telling you how good it tasted. And a little more sauce just for good flavor. Crisp dill pickles and a sesame seed crown. These early TV ads relied on relatively static shots. Advertisers would use a wide angle lens mounted on a camera, and it might zoom in and pan a little, but that's about it. There were lots of shots of boxes and labels. The food did just normal food stuff.
食物。列举配料，告诉你它有多好吃。再加一点酱汁，味道更好。香脆的莳萝酸黄瓜和芝麻面包顶。这些早期的电视广告依赖于相对静态的镜头。广告商会使用安装在相机上的广角镜头，它可能会放大并轻微平移，但仅此而已。有大量关于盒子和标签的镜头。食物只是做一些正常的食物做的事情。
You might see something being ladled out of a pot. You might see a spoon serving peas at a dinner table or serving cream corn at a dinner table. So that would be the extent of the motion. On top of the new challenges of television, food advertisers in the late 60s found themselves facing new scrutiny. The Federal Trade Commission was keeping a close eye on TV ads, following the now-infamous
你可能会看到有些东西从锅里舀出来。你可能会看到一把勺子在餐桌上服务豌豆，或者在餐桌上服务奶油玉米。这就是运动的程度。除了电视带来的新挑战之外，60年代末的食品广告商发现自己面临着新的审查。联邦贸易委员会密切关注电视广告，这是在经历了臭名昭著的
Campbell's Soup Incident of 1968. They were introducing a new brand of soup that had a lot of vegetables in it, but the problem is the vegetables sink to the bottom. So what they did was put a bunch of marbles in the bottom of the bowls just to hoist up the vegetables. When the FTC found out they threatened campals with legal action, the event led to a new push for truth in advertising. A lot of the old tricks advertisers had relied on in the past were now off the table. No more using glue instead of milk and cereal ads. No more substituting mashed potatoes for ice cream.
1968年金宝汤事件之后。他们正在推出一种含有大量蔬菜的新品牌汤，但问题是蔬菜会沉到底部。所以他们做的是在碗底放一堆玻璃珠来把蔬菜托起来。当联邦贸易委员会发现时，他们威胁要对金宝汤采取法律行动，这一事件推动了广告真实性的新浪潮。广告商过去依赖的许多旧把戏现在都不行了。不能再在麦片广告里用胶水代替牛奶。不能再用土豆泥代替冰淇淋。
But in the 1970s, food advertising took a radical turn. Food started moving. And that opened the door to all the fancy tricks we see in ads today. Shrimp, executing acrobatic flips, lobster claws, cracking open and slow motion. French fries bouncing across a table. Food wasn't static anymore. Food was flying. And we've got one man to thank for this new aesthetic, Albert Buden. He didn't want anything stagnant. Everything was
但在20世纪70年代，食品广告发生了根本性的转变。食物开始移动了。这为我们在今天的广告中看到的所有花哨技巧打开了大门。虾在做杂技般的翻转，龙虾钳在慢动作中裂开。炸薯条在桌子上跳跃。食物不再是静态的。食物在飞。我们得感谢一个人带来的这种新美学，阿尔伯特·布丁。他什么也不想要停滞不前。一切都是
always moving. He wanted to romance the food or whatever was said in front of it. This is Harry Drennan, who spent years working for Albert Buton. That's how he met his wife, set director Jackie Kanto. I've been in the film business for 35 years, 40. I don't want to say a lot. The ads that Kanto and Drennan made with Buton until his death in 1996 were unprecedented. Working with clients like McDonalds, Burger King, and Coca-Cola, Putin invented a whole new visual language
一直在动。他想给食物浪漫化，或者在食物面前说任何话。这是哈利·德雷南，他在阿尔伯特·布丁手下工作多年。这就是他如何遇到他的妻子、布景指导杰基·坎托的。我从事电影行业35年、40年了。我不想说太多。坎托和德雷南与布丁合作制作的广告直到1996年他去世为止都是前所未有的。与麦当劳、汉堡王和可口可乐等客户合作，布丁为食品广告创造了一种全新视觉语言
for food commercials and really pioneered the genre of advertising known as tabletop. Many of the terms and techniques that tabletop directors still use date back to Putin. For example, the prep shot, which tells the backstory of the product, showing all that goes into making the food.
并真正开创了被称为桌面广告的流派。桌面导演们今天仍在使用许多术语和技术都可以追溯到布丁。例如，准备镜头，它讲述了产品的背景故事，展示了制作食物所付出的一切。
You know the ones, chopping a crisp pet of lettuce, dicing some juicy red tomatoes. He would make these elaborate banquet things of raw ingredients, and that was his look. And creve shots. That's when the camera zooms way in and lingers on some tantalizing bite of food on the end of a fork. Sexy in a way, you know, it's almost food porn, you know, it's made it all real tactile to you.
你知道那些，切一片脆生生的生菜叶，切几块多汁的红西红柿。他会用生食材做出这些精心制作的宴席场景，这就是他的风格。还有特写镜头。那是当镜头极度放大并停留在叉子尖上一口诱人的食物上的时候。某种程度上的性感，你知道的，这几乎就是食物色情，你知道的，它让你感受到所有的真实触感。
And the hero shot, a last magnificent look at the food on the plate ready to eat, usually in the final seconds of the advertisement. Mutant's big breakthrough was that he didn't just describe the food and promise viewers it tasted good. He made them feel actual hunger with his images. His real thing is just food in itself, its essence, is really sensual. You know what I mean?
还有英雄镜头，最后对盘子里准备吃的美食的宏伟特写，通常在广告的最后几秒钟。布丁的重大突破在于他不仅描述了食物并向观众保证它很好吃。他用他的画面让他们感受到了真正的饥饿。他的核心就是食物本身，它的本质，真的很性感。你知道我的意思吗？
If you see a hamburger commercial, you really want to eat a hamburger and that's the point of it. And I think that's what he introduced. And you'll never see it any other way now. Kanto and Drennan remember working long days and sometimes long nights to meet butons high standards and to achieve his vision of flying food and mouthwatering close-ups. They had to use a whole bunch of crazy tools. Like giant high-speed cameras that would burn through a thousand feet of film in seconds
如果你看到一个汉堡广告，你真的想吃一个汉堡，这就是它的重点。我想这就是他引入的。你现在绝不会看到其他任何方式了。坎托和德雷南还记得为了达到布丁的高标准以及实现他对飞舞的食物和令人垂涎的特写的愿景，他们工作了很长时间，有时甚至是深夜。他们不得不使用一堆疯狂的工具。比如巨大的高速摄像机，它们会在几秒钟内烧掉一千英尺的胶片
and make a ton of noise. They'd start shooting and it was like, whew! It was just this all day long. It was something. These cameras were originally designed for the military to film rocket tests. It was useful ballistic, but we were the first ones to do it with food. Thanks to these cameras, Mutin could achieve super slow motion effects. He'd take a split second of time and look jury-aid in it.
并产生大量的噪音。他们开始拍摄，就像，呼！一整天都是这样。真是不简单。这些摄像机最初是为军方拍摄火箭测试设计的。它对弹道学很有用，但我们是第一个将它用于食物的人。多亏了这些摄像机，布丁能够实现超级慢动作效果。他会抓住一分一秒的时间，仔细研究它。
He'd have oranges splash through a sheet of water. Condensation would drip down the side of a bottle. In order to get the perfect take, Budin started designing strange, rube, goldberg sort of machines to help him get the job done. These contraptions were called rigs. They ranged from simple spouts for liquid to machines that would drop pancakes into a perfect stack to catapults that would fling oranges across the studio. And sure, the production team could have just thrown the oranges by hand. But with a rig, they could get the exact same results over and over,
他会让橙子穿过水幕飞溅。冷凝水会从瓶子侧面滴落。为了拍出完美的镜头，布丁开始设计奇怪的、鲁布·戈德堡式的机器来帮助他完成工作。这些装置被称为装备。它们的范围从简单的液体喷嘴到将煎饼完美堆叠的机器，再到在工作室里弹射橙子的弹射器。当然，制作团队本可以亲手扔橙子；但有了这些装备，他们可以一遍又一遍地得到完全相同的效果，
which meant fewer takes, which meant less time and less money spent. It also meant that they could achieve a certain level of precision and artistry. It was so much prettier than other people's work as far as I could see. It was beautiful at lighting. And then once he got into all the movement, I mean, he was ahead of the curve. Lights roll, steam. Right. Out.
这意味着拍摄次数更少，这意味着花费更少的时间和金钱。这也意味着他们可以达到一定水平的精确度和艺术性。据我所见，它比其他人的作品漂亮得多。它的灯光很美。一旦他开始涉足所有运动，我的意思是，他走在了时代的前沿。灯光转动，蒸汽。好的。出。
Ready? And action. Now I'm going to just try it again. To see how mutants techniques are still being used today, Danny went to my Guffin films in New York. Okay, so just quick descriptions. My Guffin does commercials for Red Lobster, Olive Garden, Starbucks, and a bunch of other restaurants. The day Danny was there, they were shooting a chicken sandwich.
准备好了？开始。现在我要再试一次。为了看看布丁的技术今天是如何被使用的，丹尼去了纽约的麦金芬电影公司。好的，简而言之。麦金芬为红龙虾、橄榄园、星巴克和许多其他餐厅拍摄广告。丹尼去的那天，他们正在拍摄鸡肉三明治。
So they are shooting a chicken sandwich. Uh, a hero what it looks like. Uh, on a black slate with a little tray of chili peppers and garlic and stuff. A hand model stands near the edge of the table where the sandwich is displayed. So now they're doing the crowning. Crowning means the hand model takes the bun and puts it on top of the sandwich. Just presses it there, elaborately, then takes the crown off. Then the crown goes back on again. It took them all day to film this sandwich. The whole shoot precisely orchestrated, relying on highly technical tools. Downstairs in McGuffin's prop room, there are all sorts of rigs
所以他们正在拍摄一个鸡肉三明治。呃，看起来像是一个巨无霸。呃，放在一块黑色的石板上，旁边有一小盘辣椒、大蒜之类的东西。一个手模站在桌子边缘，三明治就摆在那里。现在他们正在做加冕。加冕的意思是，手模拿起面包胚放在三明治顶部。轻轻地按在上面，动作很精致，然后把顶部的面包拿开。接着再把它放回去。他们花了一整天的时间来拍这个三明治。整个拍摄过程经过精确的编排，依赖于高科技工具。在楼下的麦古芬道具间，有各种各样的装置
sitting in storage, a lot like the ones that butan developed. But these are way more high tech. Riggers today use lasers and sensors and pre-programmed motors. And depending on the shot or the rig, there can be some intense physics to take into account, like if you're trying to slice an onion in two while it's flying through the air. We break down the elements, so we know we've got to get an onion to a certain height. This is Anthony Derroberts. He's a special effects technician at McGuffin Films, and he designed a special rig just to get this shot.
放在仓库里，很像布丹开发的那些。但这些要高科技得多。现在的机械师使用激光、传感器和预编程的马达。根据镜头或装置的不同，需要考虑一些激烈的物理原理，比如你想在洋葱飞过空中时把它切成两半。我们把各个元素拆解开，所以我们知道必须让洋葱飞到一定的高度。这是安东尼·德罗伯茨。他是麦古芬电影公司的特效技师，他设计了一个专门的装置来拍摄这个镜头。
Everything's computer controlled, so when the onion's in the right spot, these two sharp knives come through, split the onion and leave you with the slice down the middle. And slices of onion are totally tumbling across a table, classic prep shot. But while Buton may have introduced rigs and action to tabletop, some directors like McGuffin's Nick Fugelstad are trying to get away from Buton's fantastical dreamscapes of flying shrimp and oranges. I think that's a little bit of an older point of view. For Nick Fugelstad, the idealized images of food that Buton tried to bring to his ads
一切都是电脑控制的，所以当洋葱处于正确的位置时，这两把锋利的刀就会穿过去，把洋葱劈开，中间留下一个切片。洋葱片在桌子上翻滚，这是经典的备采镜头。但是，虽然布丹可能把装置和动作引入了桌面摄影，但有些导演，比如麦古芬的尼克·富格尔斯特ッド，正试图摆脱布丹那种充满飞翔的虾和橙子的奇幻梦境。我认为这是一种稍微有点过时的观点。对尼克·富格尔斯特ッド来说，布丹试图带入广告中的那些理想化的食物形象
just don't cut it in a world that's now totally saturated with food porn. While Budin's commercials often zoomed in so close to food that you couldn't see the space around it, tabletop directors like Fugelstad now frame their food in a space that you might see out in the world, like at a restaurant or a barbecue. You know, when you dig into a lasagna,
在一个如今彻底被美食色情片饱和的世界里，已经完全不管用了。虽然布丹的商业广告经常把镜头拉得离食物非常近，以至于你看不到食物周围的空间，但像富格尔斯特ッド这样的桌面导演现在把他们的食物框在一个你可能会在现实世界中看到的空间里，比如在餐厅或烧烤店。你知道，当你切开一份千层面时，
do you want it to sauce to go all over the place? When you to taco, it, stuff got to fall out? Yeah, so let's shoot that. Let it, the flavors mix. It's all right, it's what tastes good. But the thing to remember is this. On the set of a food commercial, everything, everything is highly orchestrated and contrived,
你希望酱汁到处都是吗？当你吃塔可时，里面的馅料应该掉出来吗？是的，那就把它拍下来。让各种风味融合在一起。没关系，这才是好吃的味道。但要记住的是：在美食广告的片场，每一样东西，每一样东西都是经过精心编排和设计的，
even if the ultimate effect feels somewhat natural. Because a 30-second TV spot by a firm like my Guffin can cost literally hundreds of thousands of dollars. So it's got to do one thing to make it all worthwhile. Sell a lot of food. I would say the number one rule in food advertising is that the first taste is always with the eyes. So you're trying to create a shot that makes somebody's
即使最终的效果感觉有些自然。因为像麦古芬这样的一家公司制作的30秒电视广告，成本可能高达数十万美元。所以它必须做一件事来让这一切变得值得。卖掉大量的食物。我会说，食品广告的第一法则永远是秀色可餐。所以你要努力创作一个能让人
salivate. This is Terry O'Reilly again and he's fascinated by the links people go to sell something. He tells a story about working on a commercial for a hamburger company and watching an actor do take after take biting into a hamburger and then gazing into the camera with a look of total satisfaction on his face. Then you cut and then there's the spit pale. Right beside the actor and then they just spit it right into the pale. You know, cut.
流口水的镜头。这是特里·奥赖利，他又一次对人们为了卖出东西而付出的努力感到着迷。他讲了一个故事：有一次他参与拍摄一个汉堡公司的广告，看着一个演员一遍又一遍地咬汉堡，然后眼神中带着无比满足的神情凝视着摄像机。然后导演喊卡，旁边就放着一个吐痰桶。就在演员旁边，他们就把食物直接吐进桶里。你知道，卡。
And you watch that happen 40 times or 30 times or 20. And it's so hilarious to me, just the mechanics of advertising. The illusion and the reality of creating it, that's exactly it in a nutshell. The story was produced by Danny Lewis with Avery Trouffleman and Delaney Hall back in March of 2016. We have over 350 episodes in the 99 PI catalog,
然后你看着这一切发生40次、30次或20次。这对我来说太滑稽了，广告的机制就是这样。制造它的幻觉与现实，简而言之就是如此。这个故事由丹尼·刘易斯与艾弗里·特鲁夫曼和德兰妮·霍尔于2016年3月制作。在《99%无形》的目录中，我们有350多集，
just like that one, and most of them are what we call Evergreen, so they're just as relevant today as they were when we produced them. So go into your podcast app and just download all the old episodes. Don't worry about the episode title and description. All the topics will seem boring. That is almost the point, but trust me, you will love them. If you go and download all the old episodes right now, I could probably see that in our stats and that would be really fun to watch and you will enjoy listening to them too,
就像那一集一样，而且其中大部分都是我们所说的常青内容，所以它们在今天和我们制作时一样具有现实意义。所以去你的播客应用里下载所有旧的剧集吧。不用在意剧集的标题和简介。所有的主题听起来可能都很无聊。这几乎就是重点所在，但相信我，你会爱上它们的。如果你现在去下载所有旧的剧集，我大概能在我们的数据统计中看到，那会非常有趣，而且你也会喜欢听它们的，
so it's a win-win. The Out of That Story was produced by Avery Troll from Men Mix and Tech Production by Sheree Fusif, Music by Sean Rial. Katie Mingle is the senior producer Kurt Cole State is the digital director. The rest of the team includes senior editor Delaney Hall, Emmett Fitzgerald, Taren Mousa, Vivian Lee, Sophia Klatsker, Joe Rosenberg, and me Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7 KALW in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row, in beautiful, downtown, Oakland, California. 99% invisible is a member of Radio Topia
所以这是一个双赢的局面。该故事的外景由艾弗里·特鲁夫曼制作，混音和技术制作由谢丽·富西夫完成，音乐由肖恩·里亚尔创作。凯蒂·明格尔是高级制作人，库尔特·科尔斯特是数字总监。团队的其他成员包括高级编辑德兰妮·霍尔、埃梅特·菲茨杰拉德、塔伦·穆萨、薇薇安·李、索菲亚·克拉茨克、乔·罗森伯格以及我，罗曼·马尔斯。我们是旧金山 91.7 KALW 的一个项目，制作于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市美丽市中心的无线电街区。《99%无形》是来自 PRX 的
from PRX, a fiercely independent collective of the most innovative shows in all of podcasting. Find them all at radiotopia.fm. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet me at Roman Mars in the show at 99PI org, where I Instagram, Tumblr, and Reddit too. But you can peruse the full selection of hot and tasty design stories and all the class cubbies deposit your quarter in the slot and then it's all yours at 99pi.org.
RadioTopia 的成员，这是一个由所有播客中最具创新性的节目组成的激烈独立的集体。请在 radiotopia.fm 上找到它们。你可以在 Facebook 上找到本节目并参与关于节目的讨论。你可以在 Twitter 上@我 @Roman Mars，也可以在节目官方账号 @99PI org 上找到我们，我在 Instagram、Tumblr 和 Reddit 上也都有账号。但是你可以在 99pi.org 上浏览全部精选的热门且诱人的设计故事，并在所有经典的格子里把你的硬币投进槽里，然后它们就全是你的了。
you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
本集目前还没有评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可发表评论。